[Music]
hi everybody i'm josh welsh president of
film independent welcome to film
independent presents i'm very excited to
be here today to have a conversation
with cast and filmmakers behind the
great new film seven days um before we
get started just a couple quick thanks
from film independent we want to thank
our lead sponsor of film independent
presents the hfpa and also our partner
in crime vision media without whom none
of this would be possible thank you so
much
to both of you for your support um with
that i'm really excited to talk to this
group we have a big group of people um
let me begin by introducing them uh the
writer and director rashaan sethi rashan
thank you for being here
the co-writer
and actor kharan sony
the producer liz cardenas uh spirit
award nominated producer for uh the john
cassavetes award for never going back i
want to mention
um so happy to have you here
um
another actor and ep on the film
geraldine
viswanathan i hope i'm pronouncing your
last name somewhat correctly
um calling in from australia thank you
for being here
and last but certainly not least you all
know him as mark duplass but following
this movie i will only think of him and
address him as daddy
cross
amazing daddy
thank you
um
well you all thank you so much for being
here and congratulations on the film i
really loved it it's so fresh and
unexpected
and unpredictable
um
um
i mean to start rashaan do you want to
talk about
well you and karen wrote the script
together can you talk a bit about sort
of
where were you in your lives when you
decided to write this how long ago was
it what was the writing process like and
what was your sort of initial
inspiration
yeah well i'm a physician but also a
screenwriter and i had been writing for
all of residency and i'd written many
many movies and none of them had gotten
made and i was feeling increasingly
frustrated with that
and then uh when kovet hit it seemed
like nothing would ever be made and
karen was separately
feeling a similar frustration because
the show he was on had been postponed
somewhat indefinitely both of us felt
creatively sort of vacant
and we decided together that we wanted
to write something and then take the
even bolder step of making it so we
wrote the script
in uh five days and um then sent it to
mark
and the rest of history
wow
but mark and current as i'm sure they'll
talk about go way back so that
yeah
so wait but i want to hone in on the
five-day
angle here you wrote the script i mean
this must have been an idea you've been
toying with or mentally thinking about
for some time i mean
yeah well actually oddly enough um i
initially my notion was i think so much
worse than what curry made it into but i
just thought let's just make a contained
movie with two people and it can be just
like a rom-com sort of a generic rom-com
but current had the idea of making it so
specific to our culture and bringing an
arranged marriage and the dating
websites that so many of our relatives
are on and so it kind of evolved out of
a conversation but that conversation
began like literally three days before
we wrote the script it wasn't like
months of pre-contemplation we were just
we felt an itch so
and was the idea from the beginning for
karen to star in it were you making
something like thinking okay who do we
know who can we work with immediately
yeah that was definitely you know um
i was he was just trying to get me to
shut up about not working as an actor so
[Laughter]
um that was helpful with that um yeah i
think that was we just kept thinking try
to before diplos was involved ironically
we would have these conversations like
how would duplass make this move we've
got to be simple so like i'll act on it
too and then we'll use like some other
actor friends and like we'll just make
it and we'll just it's all about just
trying to make something and then we
ended up having duplos involved and it
made the whole process so much easier
because we were going in pretty like
blissfully ignorant about what it's like
to make a movie at this level and during
it and um you know our initial like sort
of idea was like we'll just put together
some money and shoot it on a phone and
we could have done that version but i'm
glad we did this version um and we sort
of learned so much from this experience
because one of the things that
duploss was really good with do was like
they were like you're gonna be involved
with every single step so from like
literally the ground up so we were able
to get like a film school education and
like independent filmmaking so wow
amazing
um so geraldine you're i don't you're
based in australia so
i don't know if you were you here at the
time when they when this was coming
together or how did you get involved in
the project
i was in i was in new york
and they sent me the script and i read
it immediately because i had nothing to
do
and this was in like august oh no july
it was like deep
pandemic
and
i just fell in love with it and i knew
that if anyone was gonna pull this off
it would be karin and russian so i was
like i think i'm gonna get on a plane uh
i don't know how i think i'm gonna wear
a beekeeper's suit or something i was
like
we're just gonna dive in and yeah and we
did and it worked out and but it was it
was wild it was really
um
it was bizarre and it was it was a scary
time to travel but it was worth it
clearly
so i understand you and karen have
worked get together previously so you
had sort of an on-screen relationship
that
i'm sure came in handy when you were
getting to doing a low-budget film
together oh my gosh yeah it was on top
of just we were just we were writing it
for geraldine the whole time that was
one of our other little discussions
before and
and we just kept getting excited
thinking about her saying a lot of these
lines and being in these scenes and then
when she agreed to do it it was
incredible for multiple reasons but
um also because yeah we made this movie
in you know eight shooting days in a
middle of a heat wave in palm springs it
was 124 degrees the day we shot
exteriors and you know there was no
trailer there was no comfort so
it's always nice when you have a
shorthand with the person you're already
working with because otherwise i think
me and russian would spend the entire
time just apologizing to whichever
actress was there
and just being like did she sneak out in
the middle of the night and like you
know leave um but it was like you know
with geraldine like maybe she'll warn us
before she bails on this endeavor but um
yeah it was it would have not have been
the same if we i think didn't know each
other
so i mean your your relationship is
obviously it's the film it's right it's
so central and it's the joy of watching
the film is watching the interplay
between the two of you and i i mean i
love how the film is both a rom-com
you know it's got the meat cute it's got
a lot of the elements of a rom-com but i
feel like it also really subverts the
rom-com
in really
fresh and ways that i just loved and
geraldine especially coming from you
like
any moment you have to deflate someone's
romantic expectations or views of love
or
the way you take your first drink and
just
like
you know you're you play against the
rom-com in a way that i'm like wow okay
this is a movie i have not seen before
um can you talk about sort of how you
approach that and and finding your
character
yeah yeah that's true i guess it's not
your typical like rom-com heroine where
she's like
i'm trying to find love and
i feel like yeah he's more the
idealistic romantic one
um
and it was fun to play to play that just
someone who's like
really
blunt and like realistic about
in her expectations of love to the point
where she's like
not even really interested in it
um
yeah i thought that was like really
clever writing from
these guys and was really excited to
play a kind of
rom-com heroine like that
i i was thinking about it it feels like
the movie in on one level is pure it is
definitely a covid movie you made it
during covid
you reference what's going on in the
world
but
and it and it forces them into this
confinement together but aside from that
i feel like this movie has nothing to do
with covet it's about
people stripping away the layers of
inauthenticity that they live by and
under and you know it's that i mean
the basic question of about marriage and
relationships has nothing to do with
covetous dick you could have made this
at any time
um which i really again i love that
about the film
um
but i also felt like in terms of how you
dealt with covid i mean you've talked
about a little bit but
what were the challenges when you were
in production aside from the heat
and the low budget aspect of it i mean
you you were what what month did you
make this was it september
september yeah and
the biggest challenge was testing
because of the limited budget it became
a huge percentage of the budget just to
test everyone as frequently as we needed
to we did pcr tests on everybody which
was all 11 cast and crew and producers
everyone included every other day
because the 72 hour rule was only
possible
if we tested every other day because of
how long the labs were taking then and
in addition to how long the labs were
taking we had to deal with the commute
that those tests had to take so we were
in palm springs and we had to order labs
that were done in los angeles and then
ferry them back and forth and deal with
these concierge practices that were just
then starting to practice a pop-up and
do testing and now i think it's also
seamless back then it was the wild west
we were talking to random labs and
directly them and
waiting for results the night before
and
rashan's getting like the emails like in
the middle of the night making sure that
we can continue filming um but it was it
was also an amazing experience for all
of us as a team to really feel like a
family and that's another thing that i
know um duploss brothers really um
promotes is this you know going away
isolating yourselves and really making
having that like creative spirit and so
it kind of worked for us in both the
making of the film and then also keeping
everyone safe we were literally like
filming in a bubble not interacting with
the world whatsoever
routine in advance having all of our
testing in advance so safety was the of
the utmost importance to all of us um
but then it was also again taking a page
out of the duplos playbook and and all
of their support and encouragement of
like literally make this a family have
that creative team
spirit which i think
led into the film and it was a magical
experience
so mark and liz how did you get involved
like at what point market so
karen said
the script came to you
you wrote the script in a handful of
days sent it to you and then you were on
board but what was that like what's the
back story here how did you get involved
and what drew you to the project
well i mean karen and i have been
friends for a long time we you know uh
we made safety not guaranteed together
you know i don't know 10 years ago um
and struck up a friendship then um and
since then have expressed a desire to
work together in various and sundry
different ways um he came in and played
a role in in room 104
um
learned an entire 30-page script and a
day and a half
did the
entire thing on his own but it also
showed me what he could do as a leading
man and i checked that in the back of my
mind and i wanted to keep that fire
burning for him and then he came and
directed an episode of room 104 with us
um
and we've been talking for a little
while about you know when when is it
going to be the time for for karen and
russian to sort of break out and make
that first movie um and this was
a perfect fit on so many levels but you
know there was something new here that
we hadn't done like we had made some
movies in the pandemic like language
lessons that were all you know video
chat movies but we hadn't gone on set
yet to make something so this felt
different and challenging and and to the
guy's point
you know for those of you who are in the
film business there's a whole workflow
now that is established for how to keep
people safe during shooting uh of cove
and stuff but back then it was we're
just making it up and what i always tell
people is like look you're gonna have to
do multiple roles on a set but what i
didn't anticipate was
roshan who is also
a doctor um became our coveted
compliance officer and the co-director
the director of the film and co-writer
so you know the whole time
and we had the best one possible i mean
it was incredible and he kind of helped
develop some of these things that that
that are the protocols we see now so i
got my own lesson in um and double
tasking from from them and um you know i
i just knew that like this project was
birthed from the very spirit that we
birthed things like the puffy chair and
and
when they called me it was with the same
sense of
enthusiasm deep humility
and desire to go make something and
whenever i see that i want to be able to
support um and so that's when we got you
know liz involved who really was day to
day on the ground producer you know in
the trenches with everybody making the
magic happen
yeah um another film independent
connection i did the film independent
producing lab
years ago and my mentor was
mel eslin president of duploss brothers
productions beautiful and i was always a
huge fan of mark and jay and duploss and
what they did and and and also mel and
so i was so honored and grateful to
that she agreed to be my mentor and then
we got to be close and
talked and about trying to work together
over the years and then she reached out
to me like geraldine was saying like
it's july 2020 it's like hardcore
pandemic and she was like i don't know
where your head's at in terms of like
getting back to making movies and being
on set um but we've got a amazing
project and we need like marco saying a
producer to be there on the ground
be creative producer for russian um but
also kind of oversee all the logistics
and um and so i met roshan and karen via
zoom
uh and fell in love with them i read the
script loved the story i loved how mark
and mel and the whole team were like
supporting this diverse story and these
diverse filmmakers
and i thought if i'm gonna get my feet
wet in producing um having a harvard md
as my director was probably pretty smart
um and it was so it was
it all happened organically i think
every kind of step of the way and was a
big fan of clarence as an actor and
geraldine's as an actress and could
totally see them in this in these roles
and it it was both a pure
joy extremely challenging and also
learned a lot in the process
could you talk could could you all talk
about i'm really curious about geraldine
well geraldine's character's apartment
um which was like a primary set and it's
such an amazing space like i loved
visually it was i just loved being in it
and there was like always something to
look at and explore
and um
talk about what was that just an
apartment you found in palm springs or
how did you
what well
credit to liz for um hunting we had
almost decided and picked where we were
going to shoot it which was a place that
was much blander than what you saw in
the movie and uh liz found this kept
searching
um which is very reflective of liz's
personality and found an airbnb in palm
springs that uh from its pictures didn't
look super promising but we went to the
airbnb and uh the place itself was quite
boring but then the lady who showed us
the airbnb said do you want to see my
house we're like okay and we walked into
the house that you see in the movie just
exactly as it is all those horses and
dust and americana and paraphernalia and
we were uh we were riveted
not only because it was visually
interesting but because
it was just it was like a frontier house
with all the americana and the idea of
doing a story about two immigrants and a
very immigrant story in
that was just funny and interesting to
us
it was also a 40 acre horse ranch and
there were over 37 horses a bull a dozen
donkeys who on the first day ate the
craft service
plastic and then they [ __ ] everywhere
and that was our first day
then we had to have a ba guard the
crafty door um and we six dogs uh
unlimited cats there was no number
because they were all just feral um and
an iguana
that was kept in an iguana room not in a
cage
and she insisted it had to be in the
house and it would escape often onto
where we were filming and then our
camera operator would lure it away with
bananas
[Laughter]
there was no air conditioning in the
home so honestly it did look hot in the
in the home but i thought that was
really good like geraldine you were you
were definitely you know
it was hot yeah
it was crazy
i felt like i was in a fever dream like
one like going from truly nothingness
and being inside and being like what is
life to being in this insane environment
where we're literally melting
i was like there's no way that this is
real
i mean really the fenton twins did an
amazing job with enhancing that space
with the curtains and shears and so much
credit goes to them too and then um
jeremy mackey the cinematographer who
was also one of the camera operators
just did such an amazing job of bringing
that space to life because it's one
place to see it and be in it but the way
he shot it was just incredible yeah i
agree with that jeremy's been a
collaborator of ours he's been a gaffer
of ours for for years worked on all of
our movies with lynch elton from you
know seattle and washington and this was
such a great movie where
a lot of people were getting their
firsts and it's something i really
believe in deeply you know if we can
ever
have a mission statement is a lot about
giving everybody their first crack and
you know
you see with roshan and karen like
having the chance to write their first
script and how passionate they were
about it and really seeing karen and
like uh in a leading man role like this
was something that's
well overdue and jeremy mackie who moved
from gaffer up to director of
photography you know and and giving liz
those reigns and saying
you know
you you go for it i i'm rarely
disappointed um
by
giving somebody that first shot
promoting them and and their enthusiasm
and their work ethic always sort of
uh makes up for whatever lack of
experience there is and in my opinion
and this film really is just
just filled with that ethic
yeah absolutely
um
uh karen and geraldine
another question on sort of
your performances
um
well you shot how many shooting days did
you say there were eight
that's insane so you i don't know how
many pages you were doing today but this
is a dialogue driven movie you guys are
just
back and forth
uh how did you i mean one there's just a
technical question about how do you
how do you do that right i mean
obviously you're experienced actors but
and you had a rapport but that's a lot
to take on but beyond that like a more
nuanced question is sort of
there's such an
emotional interplay through your
dialogue where things are revealed and
held back and
there are these pivots like how do you
navigate that as performers working
under such tight conditions
and i mean maybe it's also a question
for you rashaan in terms of how you were
directing them and
when you intervened and what was that
interplay like
i think i just asked like five questions
but
well i can start really briefly and then
let them answer about the performance
piece just to say that they had to do 15
to 17 pages of dialogue a day
and not only memorize it but often only
have one or two takes because of the
speed with which we were moving um and
they are both such natural instinctive
performers never got in their head did
just an incredible job it was uh
mind-blowing to me because i had never
worked so intimately with actors to see
what both of them can do but they're
just both so talented
and they improved a great deal too like
rash and i had the hardest time not like
laughing by the monitor or crying
because we
felt that way many times yeah my laughs
are edited out of the movie there were
many of them
wow i mean it was really bizarre like i
think um it was the first time i had
like been part of the writing process
and then acting those scenes out so i
felt like they were with me for a few
months before but i feel like if this
was just like a job that came to me
would be way more intimidating just the
amount that was happening but
um i really because like you said it was
made during covered like i really during
that time in kobe really thought like i
would not work again because the idea of
like film sets coming back when we were
like in the summer of 2020 talking about
like people staying away from each other
even outdoors like six feet i'm like how
are we gonna
film something on this set so i really
was like i think this is like all
changed forever in a weird way and then
i was like i don't know if i can still
even do this and then it was just
literally the first scene doing it being
like oh the joy is back like this feels
familiar in a time where everything felt
like so crazy and new and every day
you're like oh this is different now get
used to it um the actual acting was like
oh my god this i know how to do like
this
and this was like a chance to be so
creative and i it was it made me fall in
love with acting again in a weird way as
crazy as the whole thing was
you know it's funny karen you and i
haven't talked about that thing where
when you are a co-writer of something
and you're an actor in it
um
it's that much more shameful and
embarrassing when you drop one of your
lines
which happens to me all the time because
you get a little cocky because you're
like oh i wrote it and i'm fine and
maybe you don't memorize it that much
because you're like it's mine and then
you show up oh [ __ ]
i don't know this as well as i could
i've had that problem before yeah you
can't complain that it's too wordy
because yeah yeah
um
well
i i mean i want to go back on just the
the central
uh
thing in your performances of that
gradually revealing yourselves more i
mean geraldine you reveal yourself
pretty
fully early on like you get caught and
then you're just like all the pretense
is gone but then there remains this like
playful quality to how you relate to him
as he gradually opens up
and karen i love this when she's in the
hospital and you're having conversations
with her mom on the phone and seeing the
evolution of that relationship was just
beautiful and like again unexpected and
just showed like a different side of
your character where
you know a different performer or a
different script would have had i could
imagine a bad version of that where like
you just remain uptight throughout or
you know putting on this pretense the
whole way but like
the way you gradually crumble and become
more yourself
i was beautiful to watch um
really from both of you
um which leads me to question i'd love
to hear hear about how you came the
framing device of the movie of the the
real couples at the beginning and end
where did you find them and how did you
film them
um i thought that was really
beautiful
yeah well initially the inspiration came
from when harry met sally and the idea
was to film three or four couples that
were scripted with actors and then to
intercut them throughout the movie so
exactly what when harry mancelli did but
we came up with the better idea in the
end of interviewing our own relatives so
all those people in those videos are
people who are related to us um one
couple is actually kern's parents the
basically the funniest ones with looking
for the tissue and that's current
um but uh then you came up with this
notion of doing
at the beginning setting up the
awkwardness of how they first met each
other how little they knew each other
how far of a journey it felt like they
had to travel and then at the very end
of the movie hearing how many years each
of them had been married and what they
meant to each other one of the most
emotional things for us when we were
making the movie was in doing these zoom
interviews we started asking people who
were related to what do you mean to each
other which is not a question that you
would casually ask any of your relatives
but we asked them and recorded their
answer and it would make us cry and them
cry and there was something so beautiful
about you know these
everyone you see in those videos just
met as strangers and then built this
life together i remember early on when
you guys brought the script to me i i it
was great for me to kind of examine my
own blind spots about what arranged
marriage was and
and it's been presented a certain way in
media whether it's you know either just
sidelined or sort of marginalized for
joke purposes or whatever that is um
and and listening to karen and russian
sort of talk about um
something that i have deeply believed
which is you know that love is something
that that can grow and that you can
water and that you can come together and
i've seen it in my own marriage and i
found a connection point to something
that i had previously seen as culturally
niche or something that i just wouldn't
be able to understand um
and i i loved the core of that and i
think those videos um really helped to
drive that home
yeah yeah and on a practical note like
the script we needed more
pages
[Laughter]
it was very hard to write a movie of
just two people in one place and me and
rash and always were like we don't want
it to be boring and so we were always
like thinking and we're like we think
we've done everything we can do with two
people in the house and then we were
like maybe this will help us you know
get some screen time on this movie well
but to that point you just made it it's
very dramatic moment when you leave the
house at the end and you're walking down
the sidewalk with your little backpack
like that was such a great shot and it's
like oh we're in the world
when you guys meet and the camera's
circling you like that was you know
cinematic gold
you know after being cooped up
yeah that was kind of what russian
wanted to he wanted it to feel like
you're finally getting to like
yeah like see the simple things like a
tree and the colors of that and the sky
and we got we got lucky you know there
was summer there were fires there was
like a day before where the sky did not
look like that and that was our last day
of filming and then it magically cleared
up and
we
got a steadicam operator to like drive
up for the day and like shoot that and
it was very crazy there were people in
the park and we had to like shoo them
away
yeah that was a doctor and she was like
you're a doctor
we talk about medicine but uh but yeah i
feel like the um
the the thing we were thinking about
with the ending in a weird way was the
end of the pandemic which is obviously
who knows if that will exist but the
feeling of like we'll go outside and
we'll lower our masks and we'll see each
other and the emotion of that and how
that felt in september 2020 how urgently
we wanted that then and how much we want
it now because that was the first of
many things we lost in this pandemic was
the connection the face that you know
all of that so for us that was the
emotion to end on because it was so much
the spirit of the time yeah
i think it'll be really interesting to
see how movies from this era play in
like five years like i think they're
gonna have emotional resonances that we
can't even predict now
because of course we don't know what the
world will be like in five years or how
you know uh yeah how we'll look back on
this time um
yeah i think it i wonder that all the
time because um you know we forgot about
1918 somewhere along the way right so it
did you know it did eventually fade um
but
but we wanted to make something that was
very true and honest to how we were
feeling for better or worse that is what
we
did so um i have one last question which
is for you rashaan and i'm just
i'd love to hear you talk a bit about so
you're you're a doctor and a filmmaker
can you just talk like i'm very curious
about that how you balance those or do
you balance them
what's you what you where did you start
how did you get into the
move into the other one
i started well i started in medical
school and i really wanted to write so i
started cold calling producers of
medical shows offering myself as a
consultant though i was still in medical
school and did not know any medicine but
i told them over like facebook that i
was you know willing to offer my medical
expertise and cold called so many people
finally one person replied amy holden
jones who um hired me to work on a pilot
as a consultant and eventually um helped
get my spec script to an agent then i
got staffed and i
wormed my way into the industry mainly
as a writer
and it wasn't really until this movie
that i even thought about actually
making something um but like i said at
the beginning i have been writing
features for years and have written at
this point 15 features and um i didn't
get one made until we made it so it was
so i had no idea that we could just go
make a movie like i really wish i had
known that um i had always waited for
permission and for the call and i think
karen had a similar feeling too which i
think it's almost worse as an actor in a
lot of ways but for the two of us to
feel like empowered and like we could
just go out and make it which we're
really grateful to mark for making us
feel that way was really
um life-changing
it's great to hear i mean mark i'm sure
you know this but i like and obviously
there are other independent filmmakers
taking a similar path but what you've
done
what you and jay have done and with mel
and the people you work with and
supporting emerging filmmakers coming up
like doing what you did with puffy chair
and like
passing that on is just really inspiring
and so valuable to
the film world it's like you know it's
like because yeah so many people are
sitting around waiting for permission or
waiting for some
big budget authority to say i bless your
project and now you can make it and it's
like it's a whole different approach
when you start from like
we're a couple brothers and we're gonna
go make a movie on our own about a puffy
chair and then and it's beautiful you
know
um saying that and thank you for all of
your support through the years and
everything that you guys have done you
know i mean we we
we saw that we saw the system you set up
and all those awards you give to people
and and
you know
it it as you well know um you know
there's a part of it yes you you you
want to do it to give back but at the
end in the end it is really so
gratifying and uplifting you know um to
get to
my age at this point where your
priorities start to shift and i've i've
i've already sort of climbed the couple
of mountains that i assumed would make
me happy which are you know getting your
own success and telling your own vision
then you get up there and it's fun for
a little while and then you look around
for something more meaningful and this
this gives me
probably a lot more than i give back so
um
thank you for saying that and thank you
for what you guys do in the same regard
[Music]
you